well a video posted on the nextdoor app
is just getting so much attention it
involves kids on dirt bikes at parks
this is all happening in the area of
mountains edge parkway in buffalo sally
jaramillo sharing neighbors frustrations
i see these this group almost daily and
you get to know their bikes a southern
highlands resident who didn't want to
show his identity tells me there are
concerns over the riding of dirt bikes
in the neighborhood we're seeing a lot
of groups of people on dirt bikes
coming through and it seems like the
groups are getting larger and it even
sometimes includes atvs this neighbor
says the group shut down intersections a
video posted on nextdoor confirms it
they're choosing to do it not only on
the city streets but they're doing it
within several of the city parks the
video shows these dirt bikes all over
this mountain's edge regional park and
neighbors here hope something is done
before someone gets hurt it seems as if
they're going out of their way to
you know terrorize if you will people
you know with some some videos that have
been recorded of them nearly hitting a
child for everyone's safety
it's only a matter of time before
something bad happens to somebody
neighbors are fed up for these types of
shenanigans it really starts aggravating
people i feel like we're probably not
far away from some sort of road rage
type incident
live local now
reach out to the county in metro she was
told dirt bikes are not permitted in
county parks and on public roads if you
see it happening in a park you're told
to call police to report it